le 4 mai dernier une femme est morte
sous les coups de son conjoint
il a tiré dans ses jambes avant de
l'immoler par le feu alors qu'elle était
encore en vie
cette femme s'appelait chahinez boutard
elle avait trois enfants
monsieur le premier ministre
rien rien n'a été fait pour protéger
cette femme alors que tous les voyants
étaient au rouge
son mari avait été condamné à plusieurs
reprises il possédait une arme
il était sorti de prison en décembre
2020 et sa femme avaient à nouveau porté
plainte en mars dernier malgré tout cela
madame boutin n'avait pas de téléphone
grand danger
son conjoint n'avait pas de bracelet
anti rapprochement et personne n'avait
saisi son arme
en résumé monsieur le premier ministre
toutes les mesures que vous avez prises
à la suite du grenelle sur les violences
conjugales ont été absentes n'ont pas
été mises en place pour cette femme
la mission d'inspection a rendu ses
premières conclusions ce matin elle
parle d'une série de défaillances et de
dysfonctionnements on croirait entendre
une annonce de gares pour annoncer le
retard d'un train
monsieur le premier ministre
tous les meurtres de femmes ne peuvent
pas être évité celui là aurait dû l'être
si vous vous étiez donner les moyens
d'appliquer des lois que vous avez
vous-même voter
ma question est donc simple n'avez vous
pas honte d'une telle inefficacité de
votre politique
merci on vous répondre
[Applaudissements]
elop
la parole
la parole est à monsieur le garde des
sceaux
[Applaudissements]
ce qui parfois me fait honte c'est
l'exploitation c'est l'exploitation
c'est l'exploitation cynique cynique et
obscène d'une situation que nous avons
tous à déplorer avec beaucoup d'émotion
nous avons fait bien plus que vous
je vis les gens jaloux le tiers-monde et
aures
vous répondez dans le respect j'ai
appelé tout le monde au respect au début
de la séance
vous répondez en respectant l'auteur de
la question
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas s'il demandé au premier
ministre si la honte c'est et
respectueux et j'entends vous répondre
sur ce registre
je redis donc que c'est nous qui après
le grenelle avons mis en place le
bracelet anti rapprochement le téléphone
grave danger l'ordonance ordonnance
d'éloignement un certain nombre de
résultats positifs sont dès à présent à
noter mais je le dis et je les dis
d'ailleurs il n'y a pas matière bien sûr
à faire en la matière de triomphalisme
parce qu'un crime perpétré dans ces
conditions en particulier est un crime
de trop oui il y a eu un certain nombre
de dysfonctionnements
vous connaissez parfaitement le nombre
de policiers vous connaissez le nombre
de magistrats j'ai été le premier à dire
que ce bracelet anti rapprochement
madame la sénatrice ne devait pas rester
dans les tiroirs
nous avons au ministère de la justice et
aussi le premier ministre a aucune
raison d'endosser cela distribuer les
bracelets anti-rapprochement ils sont en
nombre ils ne sont pas et ça n'est pas
de notre fait distribuer nous avons
d'emblée avec le ministre de l'ère de
l'intérieur marlène schiappa et moi même
demandé une inspection
cette inspection nous en avons pour
partie le premier rapport d'étape et
nous avons dit les uns et les autres que
nous n'aurions pas madame la sénatrice
la main qui tremble
si les dysfonctionnements sont avérés
nous n'avons pas à avoir honte d'avoir
fait ce que vous n'avez jamais fait
[Musique]